hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to contraption maker now
this is one of my favorite games or
actually this itself is not one of my
favorite games but the original game
that this was based off of it's called
the incredible machine and I'm pretty
sure this was actually made by the same
creator as the incredible machine and it
is a phenomenal game it would came out
when I was just a kid me and my dad used
to play it all the time because it was
so cool and it was a lot of puzzle
solving stuff and just this bizarre
weird world where you had to use the
most intricate and like making a Rube
Goldberg project to solve a puzzle and
that really appealed to me especially as
kids because it was just like really
really really cool so in this game and
this it's weird because I was playing
this a ton and it's almost exactly like
the original Incredible Machine was you
have a tool box here filled with stuff
that you need to use to try to figure
out a certain way to get things done and
then you take it and then put it into
the game and then hopefully connect it
all in a way that makes sense that it'll
run and do exactly what you needed to do
whether or not that happens is a big big
big question so let me try to think of
this because I've not played this level
yet so I had no idea I think all right
so here's the deal this this the look
right okay so I got it I need to
activate the security system blow up the
bridge the security system being the
explosive chemical in the red with the
little yellow sign on it so the twig is
there so what I need to do is I need to
get this put it there and then attach it
to here because I would no not there I
need to attach it to here cuz when a
ball will poke on that it's gonna do the
thing that it it's got a pool boy all
right okay so let's go woo just
everybody bear with me
cousin woo hoo okay yeah yeah that's
right okay that's right okay ah okay
that's important okay that's important
because I needed to know where that went
so now I can put this here put this here
put this on here flip it around aim it
in that bad
boy get this thing going and you can see
what I need to do
bang-bang-bang Bibby boom bang kaboom
done and everyone is dying in horrible
horrible ways so anyway that took me
awhile I don't know why it took me so
long I could have actually done that a
lot quicker but the thing about this is
is that all these different intricate
puzzles use the same framework of all
the parts but there's so many parts
there's a plethora of parts this is
parts non-stop so some parts interact
with certain elements like the mouse
goes after the cheese the cats take some
mice the cats also are attracted certain
items like the cat Ematic is able to do
something because it's got cat food in
it so if you make sense of it you can
ask to get what you need to do so I'm
trying to pop the balloon which is as
simple as putting this fan here and
making this electrical generator flip
over there I need to flip-flop that see
it's just like it's in such an intricate
puzzle system and it's so cool in that
it all just makes sense it's so cool I
mean it's it's very logical and what it
does is extremely logical okay so what's
gonna happen is this is why this is why
this is all doing that cuz okay this is
what is what is that actually okay this
I need okay I need this here and I need
this here to pull on this or no I need
on the other side cuz this yeah there's
a lifting device so if I take this and I
take the rope and I pull the rope over
there then it should go cuz that's gonna
go over there yeah but I didn't do god I
didn't do a damn thing to connect
oh the I got a guy I got okay Kay that's
gonna go over there it's gonna be
bounced up crap it's gonna hang on the
music is oddly appropriate this is what
it is this is the solution whop yes
exactly do that boy well that I'm yeah
yeah yeah just like that it's all the
room okay all right the reason I'm
geeking out so much is because this game
was such a part of my childhood like
it's such an interesting part of my
childhood too because it
kinda like established my need like
solve puzzles and and that's why like of
all the games that I like I actually
have a weird affinity for puzzle games
and something that I thoroughly
thoroughly enjoy all the time so anyway
with this one was my goal here Tim
backed himself into a corner with
nowhere to go fry all the zombies with
the laser before they can reach him you
got it how am I gonna fry him though is
a big question here
alright so either way I need to use this
laser and I need to power it up such
that I have what I need to okay so
that's probably a pole I would imagine
that that's a pole pad maybe it's a push
pad I have no idea okay but either way I
need to get that to pull that or push
that okay I got what I need to do okay
so this is acting like a timer what it
does is this these these outlets are
powered by lasers so the timer is
activated when the first zombie hits on
the hamster cage which powers this
electric generator that'll turn this on
reflect up to that sensor reflect up to
this sensor trigger that fan and then I
can connect this blue loon which is
being pulled by the pan and when the fan
goes on the bowling ball will go over
there it'll hit this hamster here and
then it'll power that generator and then
this laser will fire over there I don't
know if my mouse is being shown here it
probably is important if that is I'll
turn it on if it's not but that's
another reason why that is there so I
run this should work cuz that zombies
gonna hit there power that on blow the
fan it's gonna activate that I didn't
have that close enough okay I need to
have that a little closer okay low close
try again go a little faster push okay
there we go blue that come on come on
baby come on big there we go
zap zap fry that's right oh crap no no
now we got it now we got it cuz now it's
gonna be a little slower yeah there we
go got it okay see
you wanna mean game is really fun
because it challenges your brain and
when you get the aha moment when you've
been trying for a while it's really a
satisfying it's one of like the most
basic early puzzle games I love it it's
I love it more for its history in my
life as opposed to its history in gaming
in general but it's a great game it's
it's a great game it's a great game in
its heart I don't know why I don't know
if it probably is a mobile game because
this is exactly like what a mobile game
would be it's simplistic it's easy to
understand it's exactly what it is then
you can see everything ok so that goes
there that does that and my objective is
to get them home so we can warm up ok so
I need to get them back into here
there's a jack-in-the-box so it will
eventually go off and blammo that music
is like really pretty to hear I love the
music here it's beautiful
ok so this obviously goes there and then
what I need to do is I need to power
this but only selectively when the mouse
gets on it so to do that it keeps it off
so I can't have it on or else it'll go
too early yeah bonk can't have that
little too early so I need to get some
form of delay on here ok I get I get it
I get it ok I knew that it had something
to do with blocking the beam until the
right moment I forgot to realize that
the mouse would be there in the right
spot at the right moment so what happens
is this laser here is constantly
shooting a beam into the inverse laser
preventing it from firing so when the
when the mouse jumps all the way over on
the launch pad here jumps up goes
through the air it will eventually land
on this and then block this beam and let
this one activate and then start the box
so it'll be like this mouse goes up
house goes down is in the way Bing bong
and then mousey gets to go home yay I
did it I did a thing that one took a
little bit longer than I thought but it
was just because I knew what I needed to
do I just needed to figure out how to do
it all right open up Tim's garage so he
can get inside and warm up yeah got it
Wow I'm really far
out on this one okay ah okay what do we
got all right so that's poking in in
verse later Wow hey Tim go Tim go wow
that's cool
whoa well done all right cool then I
think I get it all right cool okay so
I'm pretty sure that TNT is set to time
with that plunger button there boom okay
so that opens up the rest of the garage
but what it doesn't do is it get doesn't
get the cat out of the way the cat needs
to go somewhere else because can easily
and on this turn this either by the way
this fan or both yeah I think that's
actually what it needs to happen this
needs to go there and this needs to turn
a generator which powers said fan okay I
got so we do it like this we do it like
this grab this will go there that'll do
that the answer we'll hit that that'll
turn on the fan that'll blow that the
cat stays on the hamster cage
everything's hunky-dory except for this
egg timer which I'm not exactly sure
where that fits in and let me see if
this works
I may not need it
I guess I didn't need it yeah I figured
it out without something I needed
yay okay so anyway that's all I'm gonna
play for now this game is phenomenal and
I think I see it's on sale this week
only it's on sale I'm not this isn't a
sponsored brandy or anything but this
week it's on sale so normally like seven
dollars I think it's one dollar this
week so check it out if you want plate
it's got a lot of puzzles and a lot of
people make puzzles you can make your
own puzzles in this game and submit them
for the community it's a little piece of
my childhood and it's an amazing game
and I love it to pieces so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for our cool videos that I've
done in the past and as always I will
see you in the next video
because ball oh you missed